six millions de français ont fait au
moins à paris hippiques en 2016 contre 8
millions en 1977 dans les années 60 le
pmu cette tendance avec son pari phare
le tiercé
moi je me demande toujours ce que ce que
l'on faisait quand tu n'irais pas le
faire c'est le dimanche à l'hippodrome
ou dans les bars pmu les paris hippiques
rassemble et brasse beaucoup d'argent
faites vos jeux marquez vos chevaux
messieurs dames pour le tiercé de ce
dimanche
depuis qu'il est né en 1954 le volume
des jeux a connu un essor considérable
et les parieurs sont chaque année plus
nombreux devant les guichets du pmu
c'est un véritable succès
regardez cette courbe en 1954 c'est
l'équivalent de quatre cent mille euros
qui étaient dépensés en paris hippiques
en 1975 c'est l'équivalent de 9
milliards d'euros soit accrochez vous
bien
vingt-deux mille cinq cents fois plus
alors pourquoi autant d'engouement pour
le sport hippique
je suis triste c'est pour gagner de
l'argent
enfin essayer d'enrayer les années
suivantes
le pmu connaît un déclin important
l'année 1998 est ainsi la pire jamais
enregistrée cette année là les dépenses
des français en paris hippiques ont
chuté à 5 3 milliards d'euros le tueur
puce paris - et la faute à qui ce qui
nous manque aux pme moi je pense c'est
sensibiliser une clientèle de jeunes
parce que la clientèle pme vieilli et il
ya beaucoup plus de personnes âgées qui
jouait mais plutôt que des jeunes
les jeux ne sont pas trop manger
en 2010 la législation sur les paris en
ligne change en france les paris sur
internet deviennent légaux le pmu ouvre
son site et se diversifie et la formule
marche
en 2011 c'est l'année de tous les
records avec 9,6 milliards d'euros de
mises la moyenne d'âge de nos parieurs
hippiques sur internet
en l'espace de 18 mois a baissé de 9 ans
avec cette nouvelle loi
une multitude de sites de paris
hippiques et sportifs voient le jour
résultat le pmu n'a plus le monopole du
marché hippiques
c'est donc une joie de courte durée pour
le pmu dès l'année suivante les minutes
avant de chuter à 7,9 milliards d'euros
en 2016 le but du jeu et d'essayer
d'avoir le meilleur produit sur internet
et donc de devenir de plus en plus gros
face au pmu difficile de lutter contre
le pmu puisque lui à son réseau de
distribution en dur mais sur internet on
peut lutter face à la concurrence des
sites de paris en ligne le pmu veut
redonner un coup de fouet la tuyère
cheval en changeant la formule du quinté
plus
[Musique]